فكوش
واحده من اهم المسائل التي تناقشناها مع
شركائنا الدوليين هي امن الطاقه وضمان
قدرتنا على اناره منازلنا وتدفئتها خلال
شتاء اوروبا والنقطه التي عبرت عنها هنا
في حوار المنامه هي ان الطاقه وامن الغذاء
والامن بمفهومه التقليدي كلها مترابطه
لذلك ناقشنا كل هذه المسائل مع شركائنا في
دول العالم وخصوصا هنا في الخليج لاننا
ندرك بانه فيما يخص ضمان توافر الطعام
للبشر خصوصا الذين يعيشون في افقر مناطق
العالم وضمان توافر الطاقه التي نحتاج
اليها لتدفئه منازلنا واداره اعمالنا
وضمان عيش الاشخاص بسلام وامان في منازلهم
فمن اجل تحقيق كل هذه الامور علينا العمل
كشركاء انا هنا في البحرين واتحدث مع
المجتمع الدولي عن تنسيق هذه الجهود مع
اصدقائنا في الشرق الاوسط